on apprenait cette semaine dans une
enquête de la presse qui est des
personnes hospitalisées ou encore
vulnérable ou en fin de vie qui sont
victimes de ce qu'on appelle des abus
spirituel qu'est ce que c'est exactement
alors les exemples qui ont été donnés
c'est des gens qui vont à leur chevet
puis qui d'une certaine façon leur
impose leur croyance leur font peur
aussi en leur parlant d' enfer de diable
ou encore qui leur font miroiter des
miracles ça d'ailleurs interpellé la
ministre de la santé daniel mais cannes
elle réagi en demandant aux
établissements santé de la province de
passer le message à leurs employés qu'on
peut pas tenter de convaincre de un
malade d'une religion d'une croyance
mais veut aussi que le travail des
intervenants soins spirituels soit
encadré qu'est ce que c'est ces fameux
soins spirituels
on va recevoir mélanie buisson c'est la
présidente de l'association des
intervenants en soins spirituels du
québec pour nous en parler bonsoir
madame bisson a far l'amore ce que la
presse disait dans ces articles
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu vent de ça
ou été témoin de cette voie ce que des
malades nous ont déjà rapporté qu'ils
avaient subi ce genre d' influence de
gens qui essaient de les convaincre de
leur foi ou de leur imposer leur foi oui
tout à fait c'est des choses courantes
qui arrive
aujourd'hui le nom jour là oui qu'est ce
que ça leur fait aux personnes
vulnérables de d'abord quelqu'un à leur
chevet qui essaient de leur imposer
leurs croyances
ils sont vraiment vulnérables qui sont
vraiment impuissant par rapport à par
rapport à ça puis souvent si on les
retrouve en pleurs et j'avais une madame
j'avais une madame qui était catholique
puis à pleurer quand je suis arrivée n'a
cependant dans sa chambre et elle avait
reçu jean de bing donc tradition et elle
était catholique la dame donc à épier
vénérable est en fait une vie donc à ce
moment alors à me demander mais je sais
pas quoi faire avec ça après nous voit
comme ça parce que c'était quand même
vulnérable donc donc ce soit pas que je
me suis occupé de sow puis j'ai enlevé
sa fille j'ai pu être restée avec elle
pour pour eux la compagnie lorsqu'elle
vivait là jusqu'à la fin de sa vie sa
demande et un doigté immense
d'accompagner des gens qui sont
vulnérables ou en fin de vie
quand on parle des soins spirituels et
déjà le terme soins spirituels quand on
connaît pas ça ça peut avoir l'air un
peu étrange parce qu'on connaît des
soins infirmiers des soins hospitaliers
c'est quoi exactement 1 soins spirituels
spirituel ça vient du
du soin dans l'éthique du souci de
l'autre donc fait que soins spirituels
c'est d'accompagner les personnes le ou
sont dans leur vécu au niveau du sens à
leur vie
donc quand une personne qui était malade
qui apprend le diagnostic de cancer puis
que ça allait fondre au niveau de
l'instance au niveau 2
le chiffre d'affaires croît de c2c
valeur parce que ou pillées ces
croyances donc dans ses croyances ça
évolue tout le temps donc c'est
personnel à chacun aussi c'est pas
nécessairement pris dans une religion en
tournée donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
formé pour accompagner ces personnes là
mais vraiment à partir de ce que vivent
et non à partir de nos propres religions
sont via compagnie ça veut dire quoi
sert asturies se crée une sorte de
confort finalement pour cette personne
confort moral mais est-ce qu'on se
confesser on fait vraiment de la
relation dead avec avec le patient la
relation ait spirituelle parce que c'est
spécifiquement où c'est spécifique ou
spirituelle parce que c'est sa relation
avec elle-même
les autres et le tout autre l'univers où
le cosmos peu importe peu importe sa
croyance en faire donc c'est quoi une
approche religieuse n'est pas en parlant
de gentilly-2 parlant d' ida ou quoi que
ce soit vous partez des croyances de la
personne tout à fait et elle sait on
vraiment c'est vraiment une approche non
confessionnelle on est formé pour sow à
l'université de montréal qui est associé
avec avec avec le chemin et notre
superviseur de l'association les
intervenants sont et spirituelle de 1,1
stages cliniques sont privilégie
toujours la formation des ss en
bioéthique santé spiritualité que donne
universités n'ont rien et à l'intérieur
de son honneur stages cliniques en soins
spirituels non confessionnelle donc
c'est hyper important parce que ça
permet d'être vigilant justement aux
abus spirituelle pour pas laisser
n'importe qui finalement qui l'impact
était de bonne motivation mais qu'il
ferait de façon extrêmement maladroite
et qui ferait du tort
fm vous avez des autorisations de la
part d'une serre de la santé d'avoir des
hôpitaux pour rentrer à l'hôpital tout à
fait parce que je tends en jetons
employés de l'hôpital puis nos
employeurs normalement entre c'est ce
qu'ils font ils prennent des gens et
prend des intervenants soins spirituels
qui ont fait le stage de l'association
canadienne des soins spirituels
donc il s'est quand même est quand même
important pour eux mais c'est pas
obligatoire c'est ce qu'on demande pour
protéger protéger nos patients en fait
on demande à la ministre de de rands
saut de rendre le stage clinique avec la
formation des ss en bio et 2 500 t
spiritualité que ce soit obligatoire
pour pas avoir à faire à tout le temps
des abus spirituel venant d'un ss ok
mais qui sont pas formés
les intervenants sont inspirés de leur
camp donc un lieu c'est ce qui est pas
fort mais il peut être formés ailleurs
parce que les pôles obligatoire cette
formation là
donc nous nous on donne justement cette
forme à cette formation là depuis 1986
les laminer ça quand même réagi cette
semaine en rappelant qu en mars dernier
elle avait déjà donné une directive à un
groupe s'occupe justement de soins
spirituels est formation qui est à
québec par exemple qui est sous la
supervision du chic et bex j'ai bien
compris
est ce que c'est une bonne idée de dire
parce que eux elle leur donne le mandat
de revoir finalement toute la politique
ministérielle qui tourne autour de ce
tout cet encadrement wyss l'a pas
laissée à elle demande à ce groupe
ces trois est santé de québec de revoir
les orientations ministérielles et ça me
fait je peux vous avouer que ça me fait
beaucoup de peine parce que nous on
al'expertise en fait
en 2009 2010 les orientations
ministérielles
on les a travaillé avec la mini star
donc pilot maintenant c'est nous c'est
plus confiants on peut plus travailler
on peut pas travailler avec eux
main dans la main j'avais l'impression
d'être déconsidéré pas déconsidérer
c'est qu'on avait expertise justement
pour en plus de ça 2 de gérer justement
les abus spirituel on ne la formation
ponk c'est ce qui campa justement les
abus spirituel donc les membres de
l'association des intervenants soins
spirituels du québec sont formés
justement à ce qui est au début parce
qu'on a une approche non confessionnelle
avec des normes de formation ils ont
peint canadienne et en plus de ça on a
un code de déontologie
ce que le centre de santé à québec ne
pas son son nouveau dix ans en la
matière le voilà à la charge du côté du
ministère justement du côté de la
ministre que nous expliquer là dessus et
votre expertise qui sont à ce genre on a
envoyé des emails on ne peut on n'a pas
de retour donc
les jeunes demandent expressément à la
ministre de boire des jus ce qu'on a
déjà fait dans le passé les orientations
ministérielles dans le travail avec le
merci on a travaillé avec le ministère
donc nous autres on veut vraiment
collaborer continue à ça parce qu'on ne
les geôles expertise qu'on ne peut pas
attendre en 2021 pour régler les
problématiques des abus spirituel auprès
des patients parce que le mandat avait
été donnée justement d'ici 2021 le
pourrait revoir ses pour laisser pour
les orientations ministérielles mais pas
pour les abus ce père et voilà écoutez
on entend votre message me saoule savoir
expliquer votre rôle qui est un rôle
méconnu en réalité merci beaucoup
d'ambition et plévenon voir